hallo ich bin georgia und sie sind
lotter charlotte bis meine tochter sie
hat sich verspätet wie immer ihr kriegt
mir die wohnung schon mal an hier und wo
ist ihr zimmer
es ist das erste mal da vorne mit
schönen großen fenster zum glück zu
wenig
danach können übernommen als sie und
ihre tochter das wünschen auf keinen
fall das zimmer kommt ohnehin nicht in
frage
also ich nehme das zimmer falls sie mich
überhaupt als mitbewohnerin wort klingt
es geht da nicht
also schau dich doch mal die straße die
ist viel zu laut der zimmer ist doch
viel zu klären
man kann sich gar nicht richtig bewegen
und dann überall dieser staub du weißt
dass ich allergisch bin
mama muss ja auch nicht einzeln und
überhaupt wäre es nett gewesen hättest
du auf mich gewartet
es zieht ihn
ich spüre die tänzerin und die miete
view ist ein richtig studiert modedesign
vor allem stress ich muss in vier wochen
eine semesterarbeit abgeben
nicht wir noch nicht so weit gekommen so
eine wohnungssuche in einem ziemlich
viel zeit in anspruch
ja das kenne ich und ich suche dringend
einen nebenjob die miete hier ist viel
höher als die in der alten wohnung aber
es ist so schwer etwas zu finden
vielleicht kann ich dir helfen meine
kumpel sucht gerade jemanden für seinen
laden und es wurde mir noch ein gefallen
siehst du das ist typisch kölsche
klüngel
so schnell lösen sich probleme in luft
auf die wohnungssuche kann es jedenfalls
abhaken
lotta herzlich willkommen in der wg wir
müssen den vertrag noch prüfen
charlotte kennt wen ich habe noch ein
termin bei dr jägers
dank philipp habe ich ein
vorstellungsgespräch im weißen holunder
da eine typische kölsch kneipe soll das
sein
ich und kellnern nein ich glaube auch
nicht dass sich das gut kann im moment
eine mail vom dekanat wie bereits
angekündigt müssen alle studierenden des
dritten semesters ein pflichtpraktikum
im bereich grafikdesign absolvieren
für die auswahl eines geeigneten
praktikumsplatz sind die studierenden
selbst zuständig das zweimonatige
praktikum ist zum ende der
semesterferien abzuschließen
also hier ist alles richtig eingestellt
scheiße ich brauche bis nächste woche
einen praktikumsplatz